لا تعتبر ناهد طبيبه الالمانيه الايرانيه
نفسها ناشطه سياسيه تقول انها نظمت قبل
ايام فقط لمجموعه من الايرانيين هنا نصبوا
خيمه امام البرلمان للتوعيه على
الاحتجاجات والقمع في ايران
تتحدثوا وتشرحوا لمن يتوقف مستفصرا عن
الاحتجاجات في وطن والديها ناهد المولوده
في المانيا زارت ايران للمره الاخيره عام
1987 تقول انها لا تفكر بزياره مجددادا
الى اوراق ايرانيه جديده ايران ترفض نزع
الجنسيه الايرانيه عني بطلبي بحجه انه قد
احاكم في المانيا واضطر للجوء الى ايران
كنت همم ناهد واحده من قرابه 200,000
المان من اصل ايراني يعيشون هنا وجهه
المحاضرات الالمانيه تحذيرا للمعارضين
للنظام منهم قبل ايام من ان السفره الى
ايران قد يعرضهم لعواقب رحيمه وربما
تواجدو ناهد هنا كاف بالنسبه للنظام
لتصنيفها معارضه فالنشطنا هنا يتحدثون عن
اشخاص
يراقبونهمس وقبل ذلك صباحا رجل كان يصورنا
ولم يكن نعرف لماذا يصور وما الذي يفعل
وسمعناها يتحدث الفارسيه على الهاتف ولكن
عندما اقترب سالناه قال انه لا يتحدث
الفارسي
مراد وصل الى المانيا قبل الست سنوات
اللاجئا سياسيا كذلك بدات تحركه امام
البرلمان لتشجيع النواب على حظر الحارس
الثوري الايراني
المخاطر التي يواجهها الايرانيون في
المانيا لا تقتصر فقط على المخاوف من
تعرضهم للاعتقال في حال سافروا الى ايران
ولكن هنا ايضا يقولون بانهم يشعرون بانهم
دائما تحت المراقبه من عملاء النظام
الايراني في المانيا
العربيه برلين